pour savoir ce que vous êtes prête à
faire par amour on va faire une
interview par amour on ne bouge pas
pendant les ting
[Applaudissements]
brasserie concentre toi on cherche un
jules
est ce que vous êtes prête à sacrifier
votre carrière par amour non
bah ouais ah non mais ça j'ai toujours
été très créateurs vous dites pour les
jours mais non mais quand on quand on
quand on aime on respecte ce que l'autre
fait classement mais mon métier c'est
celui qui m'a fait vivre et qui m'a
sortie de pas mal de choses que je
lâcherai pas non est-ce que par amour
vous vous convertir à l'islam
encore
non parce que je crois que tout ce qui
est religieux et qui empêche
l'épanouissement de l'amour etc me fait
plus ou moins peur parce que je trouve
que c'est dans l'extrême
je sais pas de jugement à porter là
dessus mais moi je pense que je ferai
pas vous n'êtes pas croyante parce que
ça le problème peut-être mais peut-être
du mal à croire quand j'ai en plus je
vois tout ce qui se passe dans le monde
à cause des religions etc moi j'ai eu un
vrai problème et invitant à cause des
religions sacoche des extrémistes oui
les extrémistes je suis d'accord avec
vous mais moi en tout cas la base est là
et c'est vrai que depuis depuis d'aidé
décidé d'aider siècle c'est comme ça non
moi je crois en quelque chose je crois
au destin je crois en une force quand
une volonté je crois en plein de choses
on est tous maîtres de nos vies et de
nos destins et et puis voilà après
chaque lancé par amour oui prendriez 20
kilos si le mec qui aime les os
wahou
un prix non non non non rien du tout à
vous droguez par amour non à héberger
ses parents par amour qui prendrait vrai
cadeau qui
pourrait jouer parce que mon papa maman
je peux donner tous mes deux mois de ce
que je suis de ce que je te connais un
homme mais va arrêter de fumer par
exemple par amour rabutin séduire sa
voix là par amour vous accepteriez qu'il
est une maîtresse
m'a servi un peu la question de la
fidélité tout à l'heure vous voulez mais
tellement voulu qu'il soit heureux vous
êtes d'accord pour qu'il ait une
maîtresse le pauvre christ en maïs en
agissant à faire souffrir quand de super
héros de le voir à l'extérieur quoi ça
me paraît logique quand même vivre à
trois par aman j'ai pas partageuse non
ouais poser des problèmes je comprends
ça me paraît sain quand même comme par
amour est-ce que vous iriez dans un club
échangiste
ça vous dit ça non
non peut-être pour voir mais je sais pas
mais je comprends que vous êtes toujours
vous n'êtes pas d'accord l'antique
voulais pas
je voudrais pas parce que je serai pas
ça paraît tout qu'on ne serait pas je
serai pas à l'aise de là dedans moi au
bout d'un moment
non sincèrement je ne pense pas que je
serai là c'est le début mais je vous en
prie je vous n'êtes jamais allé jamais
non mais tout à fait voilà ce que sa
cousine ça mais sûrement peut-être mais
en entendant
ces mesures est pas la démarche de le
faire je crois que je serais choqué
c'est mon mec me demander ça c'est pas
moi qui vous le demande
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu